foreign
[Music]
I am devornajar and I'm very excited to
get you present today a project that
I've worked on uh during the last part
of my PhD uh and it's out of the lab on
a chip for the concurrent
electrochemical detection of sarsko V2
nucleic acids and anti-stars could lead
to antibodies and saliva this project
was a huge collaboration
um and it was mostly between members of
the Visa Institute so I was working on
my PhD with Professor Jim Collins and
we're a few benches away from the ingber
lab led by Don ingber at the Beast
Institute and so this was a
collaboration between myself and Elena
from The Collins lab as well as pollen
and Sanjay from Singapore lab as well as
Josh who was visiting in the ingber lab
but the number of people who were
involved span researchers staff
Engineers clinicians who gave us access
to some of the really critical blood
samples and serum samples that we needed
to validate this platform uh as well as
the mentors that we've had and
um I myself have just completed my PhD
as I said uh between the peace Institute
as well as the MIT media lab where I was
co-advised by Jim Collins and Professor
Joe Paradiso
uh and my main interest has always been
in sensing and sensing in particular is
quite interesting we have a lot of
sensors that are dressed on our body of
course
um but those sensors only work within a
certain regime and one of the main
interests of science has always been how
do we create
um sensors that can augment the sensors
that we have on our body and make our
sensing abilities
um
at different resolutions so things that
can be really really small things that
are really far away so we've created a
lot of
um methods of being able to interrogate
the world around us by proxy methods
that are going beyond our sensing and
um in particular for biology we in the
past you know 200 or so years have
really excelled at our ability to be
able to sense particularly really really
tiny things and we've created a lot of
methods that would allow us through
direct and indirect methods to send
things like proteins and nucleic acids
which control uh our bodies and a lot of
the world that we interact with and so
uh the the main methods for instance
that we use specifically for SARS code
V2 detection so this talk will be about
um Cobra detection but there's also a
lot of broader implications for how we
can use this method for any type of
nucleic acid sensing I know that the
title of the presentation didn't have
crispr in it and this is a crispr
conference
um but we use crispr as the way of doing
nucleic acid detection which I'll get to
in a bit
um so the main ways that we have been
able to detect nucleic acids in
particular uh and also just proxies for
microbes and pathogens that we're
interested in so pcrs obviously are
indirectly or directly
um detecting
um DNA or RNA so in the case of DNA it's
direct detection in the case of RNA we
have cdna that would allow us to to
detect the RNA antigen assays are
typically
um indirect essays so we're looking for
things like proteins and
um
things that are produced by the pathogen
of Interest not the pathogen itself but
what it's what it's producing and
sequencing which is also a nucleic acid
detection method but gives us a lot more
granularity than you can get with PCR
antigen into
um the exact differences of different
microbes in it and pathogens and in
particular trying to do a lot of like
lineage detection and understanding the
evolution of those pathogens and
microbes and there are a lot of um you
know pros and cons to these three
methods they are methods that um all of
us I think have been
exposed to the previous points in our
life if you're somebody who's been
working in a laboratory on biological
um assays but you know over the past two
and a half years they're now household
names that people in your family
probably
um know and think about even if they
have never had exposure to the lab and
um I think for PCR of course this is
sort of the gold standard method PCR to
PCR that we use and the pros are that
it's really easy to design a PCR assay
as long as you have the sequence of the
thing you're looking for uh it's quite
simple to try and produce
um a set of primers that you can use to
detect
um and it's quite sensitive and quite
specific so it's really important
especially when you're trying to do
things
um that let's say It's a larger family
and you want to look at a very specific
piece within that family
um you're able to use PCR but the cons
are that there's a long turnaround for
results so most people don't have PCR
machines inside of their homes which
means that you're going to have to be
sending this out into a lab facility to
get processing and get the rest results
and that then requires us
when you have something that is
um such a bottleneck experience like
let's say a covered spike in your region
it could take upwards of a week or more
in order to get the results that you
really need as soon as possible and also
PCR is quite expensive so as far as
methodologies go usually facilities will
be using spin kits and purification
methods
um for the sample that they're taking
from you and then running the PCR on
very expensive equipment so it's not
necessarily the most affordable option
Inogen assays on the other hand
um you know it takes a while to produce
them so one of the cons is that there's
a long design process in order to create
an endogen acid that you could use in
your home that could take months of
iteration so for instance it took until
about December 2020 for there to be the
first CDC assay that was approved or FDA
approved assay for under the eua so that
we can test for uh
starts kobichi within our own homes and
there's like less accuracy that's
available so it's very possible you
could be infected with a pathogen but
because your body hasn't developed a
high enough amount of whatever antigen
that whatever the endogen acid is
looking for you won't actually test
positive but they are affordable and
pretty quick for turnaround to result in
easy to use which means that they're
great to disseminate to a large
population with the understanding that
they are less sensitive than alternative
methods and then there's sequencing
which
um is an interesting addition to this
set of wandering methodologies because
it is the most new of all of the methods
so next Generation sequencing has really
only been around and robust for the past
10 to 20 years and um it's expensive and
also I think what's frustrating is that
it produces a very large volume of data
which requires a lot of technical skill
in order to untangle and start to read
which means it's very much not meant for
a lay person
um but it does
um
not require you to know much about the
sequence necessarily so when you're in
very early stages of trying to monitor
things it can be really helpful
um and also it can monitor down to
single nucleotide differences which
means that not only are you looking at
you know let's say a large scale
um
uh pathogen of interest but you're right
you can actually go down and see
um you know snip level detection you can
do
um strain differentiation and do more
lineage as I was saying before and it's
quite robust so it can take a lot but
it's just quite expensive
um and so for me as a researcher and
also just as a person who was
experiencing the pandemic I was quite
frustrated that these were the only
options that were available especially
um you know as somebody who was stuck in
my home for a large portion of things
um I was frustrated with the options
that my family had access to and my
friends and I felt that science you know
especially within the laboratory had
progressed to such a large extent but I
realized that that hadn't been reflected
in what was available and accessible on
a market especially
um given you know how much progress
we've made in the field over the past
since 20 years
unfortunately I have been working with a
um
A system that I felt was actually quite
uh well
um suited for trying to figure out how
we can do better at home detection and
that uses as you might imagine
um crispr so crispr is a family of
enzymes you've been hearing a lot about
it if you're at this conference and the
enzyme that I'm particularly fond of is
called cast 12a and it's an enzyme that
does double-stranded cutting staggered
double stranded cutting of
um DNA and all you really need like most
crispr enzymes is the crispr enzyme and
the guide RNA which will lead you to the
Target
um and cast 12v is a special enzyme that
has this off Target
property that was discovered which is
that once it Finds Its Target Strand and
it cuts it has this extra feature which
is that it also starts cleaving all the
single-stranded DNA that's in the
vicinity of the enzyme so once the
enzyme is sort of activated when it does
the initial cleavage of the intent into
Target it sort of looks around in any
type of single stranded DNA that's in
the vicinity of it it will start
collaterally cleaving that single strand
of DNA and there were researchers in the
um in functions lab as well as in the
diagonal lab who concurrently published
systems which use cas12 as a method of
doing
nucleic acid detection in a very rapid
Manner and so the way they did this was
by adding cast 12a with a guide for
their targeted interest as well as the
DNA that they're trying to look to
cleave and a um
fluorescent
molecule which was tied through a single
stranded DNA short bridge to a quencher
which means that when the cast 12 a is
not activated and it is not in the
presence of its Target it will not
fluoresce but once the cast 12a is
exposed to its Target it will start
collaterally cleaving the
single-stranded DNA bridge between the
fluorescent quencher and the
fluorescence molecule which means that
you get a fluorescence which indicates
the presence of the nucleic acid of
interest within your reaction which is
wonderful because this means that we can
then do
um
we can try and create a tool which can
combine some of the best features of the
methods that I had just previously
listed which means we can create assays
that you can use at home that are
relatively quick quick where you can
hopefully get an answer maybe not within
15 minutes but within somewhere like an
hour
um you can get really high sensitivity
and a rapid design process to create the
primers that you would need to do the
amplification and detection of the um
um of the pathogen of Interest or the
DNA of interest and you also and well
sorry also you can use it for RNA so you
can just use your transcription so any
nucleic acid of interest in air RNA you
can use and you can also get snip level
sensitivity so if you've all listened to
the my Sherlock talk which is also
available in this conference
um they're uh my collaborator Elena and
I we showed that you can get snip level
sensitivity
um to do strain detection of SARS cov2
which was really exciting so you can
combine a lot of the really useful key
techniques from the most common methods
that have been used for detection
um all in one system and I think that
that means that you can create
um a system that can generate data
that's maybe not as good as let's say
high quality quantitative data that you
can get from a qpcr machine or a
sequencing machine but it's enough data
that you have in your own home in a very
quick turnaround time that can allow you
to make really important decisions on
how you go about your life
um and so you know taking us back to the
pandemic
um you're in your home and you're
thinking about what are my options in
your options at home are usually antigen
tests your options for leaving the home
or something like a centralized PCR
essay and in both cases you're not
getting a lot of information right
because you're just checking what your
disease state is at the moment and I
think one of the most interesting things
about the coven pandemic was that it
introduced us to the idea that it's not
only important to know whether or not
you're actively infected with a pathogen
but it's also really useful and
important to know
um the antibodies that your body has
produced against that pathogen and what
that antibody signal looks like over the
course of time so this was one of the
first times where people cared not only
about infection but also about
post-infection experience with
um a pathogen and with both of the
methods that we have currently it gives
you this very very short window of time
which is just really when the virus is
active in your body to know what's going
on so for instance when your body is
producing
um you know let's say signals you only
have about five to ten days where you're
going to have the presence of the virus
inside of your body there are some
people obviously who've experienced
um the presence of the virus in their
body a lot longer than that but those
are hopefully few and far between so for
the most part if you're infected with
Sarco V2 within the first five to ten
days of infection is when you're
actually going to have the virus
actively replicating inside of your body
and past that you have this huge signal
of all of the circumvision that your
body's going through as your body is
producing different in antibodies
against that virus and those antibody
signals are also just as important
understanding somebody's complete
disease State and so
um not only were we interested in
producing a tool that can try and help
us detect whether somebody is actively
infected with sarsko V2 but we were also
interested in thinking about how can we
widen this window can we design a
biosensor that can simultaneously
provide nucleic acid and antibody
information which was something that we
weren't seeing available so often when
people wanted to get tested it was for
one or the other so they were either
getting tested to see whether or not
they had antibodies post infection and
what the levels of those antibodies look
like to understand whether they had
long-lasting protection against the
virus or they were looking to see it by
actively infected and there was no
Multiplex biosensor that was available
that can give you a much larger picture
of what the disease that you had looked
like and we felt this was an area that
um could really use innovation
um and so we designed this system I'm
referring to it as
um Melody but it's a multiplex
electrochemical
um detection system and
we just recently published on it in
nature biomedical engineering and the
basis of the system is off of this chip
so this is an e-wrap and Chip which was
previously developed by researchers in
Don ingber's lab and it has this really
unique
um system that allows for
um
reduction of following on the surface of
the electrochemical sensors so
electrochemical sensors have been around
for a while but the difficulty has been
to get a signal that's sensitive enough
to to provide clinical level
um results for the assay and the goal
was for this chip to create a biofouling
an antibiofouling surface that can now
allow you to read down to very very very
small quantities without having to deal
with the biofile when you usually get
with biological samples and they've
created a suite of of different types of
Coatings and a lot of them use charged
materials that are flowing through this
BSA glitteraldehyde system and the one
that we were using for our particular
assay was using reduced graphene oxide
as the charged material but you can also
use things like you know gold and angled
nanowires and carbon nanotubes as ways
of also sensing but the reduced graphene
oxide glutaraldehyde BSA coding was uh
the one that we chose for our system and
it works extremely sensitively which is
previously published on and so we teamed
up with seeing burlap
um and they had been previously working
on a very standard sandwich type Eliza
assay to try and do antibody detection
for uh Stars Kobe 2 and
the beauty of this system was that we
really knew
um how we obviously innovated a lot but
um the researchers in their lab spent a
lot of time trying to choose the correct
antigens that they were displaying on
this erapa chip to make sure that we
were doing very sensitive primary
antibody selection and the way that we
were doing that was through the sandwich
assay where there was a atmb precipitate
which created a charge difference
um inside the system so if the antibody
you were trying to detect was present
there would be an hrp a poly hrp that
was recruited to the secondary antibody
which would cause the tmb precipitation
which causes a spike in the um
um the electro uh chemical current that
is running through so when you get that
difference
um you know it's the peak which is
really what we're looking for and they
had already created a multiplexed
electrochemical
um chip that looked not only at the most
common
um antibodies but actually at a suite of
different antibodies
um and that was interesting to us
because again when you're thinking about
the disease State when you're thinking
about overall
um for different people depending on
your infection you have a different
response and so for let's say people
that were never infected from sarsko B2
but got the vaccine you would have a
signal for the spike protein but you
wouldn't have a signal for the nuclear
capsid protein because you were never
exposed to the virus somebody who's
exposed to the virus would have both
nucleic acid
um Spike Anderson turbine domain or
symptom binding domain is a subsection
of the spike protein but that's the
place that has been seen to be most
hyper mutated and so that is also an
ability for us to determine let's say
for future strains
um does this person have protective
antibodies against the receptor binding
domain of a future strain a SARS cov2
and that gives you a better sense of
whether or not people are well adopted
and have enough antibodies that are able
to protect against the virus so already
this was a really exciting system
um there was very strong signals that
were correlated with the detection of
different
um antibodies that we were interested in
and we actually saw that our system
um for the antibody section was working
even better than
um traditionalizes with the blood and
serum samples that we were I'm sorry for
the serum samples that we were using and
we tested about 100 different samples
50 or so positive and 50 or so negative
for covid so that was really reassuring
was that we had when you use the
multiplex chip you had
um 100 sensitivity and selectivity for
determining whether this patient was
infected with SARS Club V2 or not and
the goal for this was to figure out how
we can combine this erap in anybody
sensing system with the Sherlock system
of being able to detect very rapidly
nucleic acids and so the typical
Sherlock system the typical detection
system it's based most commonly using
fluorescence reporter and we wanted to
figure out can we modify the typical
crispr assay to create an
electrochemical crispr system that can
give you clinical level sensitivity so
people have published previously on
methods of doing this but they weren't
down to
um let's say the one copy per microliter
or a thousand copies per milliliter
sensitivity that we were looking for
that would match the gold standard
assays that we were trying to come up
against
um and we were able to create a new
assay a Christian based electrochemical
assay if that was custom made for this
erapa chip and we actually also produced
A microfluidic system that allowed us to
autonomously run this assay to make sure
that we can have as few user
interactions as possible so that this
system can be more useful and require
less laboratory intervention and so I'll
explain a bit first about how our crispr
assay works and then I'll go a bit more
into detail about how it functions in
the context of the chip and so
with most systems of course the first
thing is to collect the biological
sample so in our case we're working with
saliva
um I think over the course of the
pandemic there were a lot of people who
were using different biological samples
for us we wanted to make sure that we
were not going to be needing any
specialized equipment so that this can
be useful as an assay within times even
when there are
um you know shortages of material or
issues with supply chain which we've all
experienced and so we wanted to avoid
things like nasopharyngeal swabs and bio
transport media luckily saliva has a
high number of both presence of nucleic
acids that we're interested in for the
virus as well as antibodies it had both
so we chose saliva as the sample and so
we were collecting for a saliva from
there we're doing nucleic acid
extraction
um for the crispr side of things and so
the method that we used in order to
extract was at first we were doing
um just traditional spin kits through
valdere assay and from there and we
moved on and use a proteinase k and
heat-based inactivation so that we can
get nucleic acid extraction and nuclease
inactivation to make sure that we were
getting a signal that was directly
correlated with the presence of our
nucleic acid and not due to things like
nucleuses in the reaction from there
we're doing nucleic acid amplification
so a lot of different Sherlock systems
build in and amplify
which allows you to more sensitively
detect the the nucleic acid of interest
in our case we were using a lamp-based
amplification system which means that we
can very um
specifically select for our Target of
interest and it also creates a very
rapid production of nucleic acids so it
makes our assay faster than other
traditional amplification assays from
there we add a biochinellated single
stranded DNA so this is where our assay
differs from the other Sherlock assay so
in a traditional Sherlock assay as I was
saying before there's things like a
quench fluorescence molecule in our case
the reporter of the system is a single
stranded biotinylated DNA and the way
that works is that if the
crispr Cleaves it then the biotin is
removed from the single strand of DNA
and if it doesn't it stays on and then
we use this reaction to flow into the
microfluidic chip and the way that the
chip Works itself is that on the chip
surface you have
um a complementary piece of PNA which is
going to be trying to attract that
single stranded piece of DNA that we're
using as a reporter in this system and
so if there's no cleavage that occurs
inside of the reaction which means that
the sarcosity 2 DNA is not present then
the full single strand of DNA with the
biotin will be recruited onto the PNA
that stopped onto the electrochemical
surface which will then recruit the
polyhrp and cause the tmb precipitation
so you'll get the signal that you would
typically get in the presence of an
antibody when there's no SARS cov2 and
in the case that sarskin V2 is detected
you do not have the presence of the
biotin because it's been cleaved from
the single stranded DNA which means
there's no recruitment of the polyhrp
and there's no precipitation of the tmb
um and so different from the antibody
assay there's actually going to be a
signal present when the stars cov2 is
not detected and there will be no signal
when the starsco V2 is detected uh and
when we ran these assays we were really
relieved and excited to see that we were
able to actually increase the
sensitivity of our system
versus the fluorescence base
um crispr assay that we were using uh to
compare the two systems and we were able
to get down to 800 copies per milliliter
or 0.8 copies per microliter
um for our electric chemical assay
versus
um euphorescent essay so we had about
four times more sensitivity for the um
electrochemical assay than for the
fluorescent essay we were also able to
have 100 accuracy so when we tested on
30 different patients saliva samples uh
we were able to fully differentiate
between the infected and the
non-infected samples which was really
exciting and so we have this wonderful
assay this crispr-based um detection
assay for
um nucleic acids and we have the
antibody direct assay for this chip
um and we wanted to figure out how do we
actually create this into a usable
system so on their own both of these
assays are really wonderful and you can
run them on on in a lab alone but how do
we figure out how to really join the two
systems and so in this case I
collaborate did with Mohammed yaffe
which is another member of the Don of
Don ingber's lab and we designed a
microphobic chip that would allow us to
try and combine all of the preparation
needed to do the nucleic acid detection
as well as the direct detection of
antibodies using the Elisa system and so
we created this really
exciting very small chip so you can see
that's the chip next to a quarter so
it's this really really tiny
microfluidic system it's run by very
small peristaltic pumps
um to autonomously move fluid throughout
the system and we use high heat
resistors as the way of providing
heating so it's a very very low power
system it uses a free volts to do the
eating for the saliva and for the
reaction and
and it's super small we went through a
lot of different iterations of chips to
figure out what was the best method of
being able to do the
um extraction and amplification and
detection of the system we wanted to
make sure that there would be a
minimization of evaporation we wanted to
minimize any type of backflow that was
happening within the channels and we
also wanted to make sure that there was
enough physical separation between the
heating elements and the um reaction
materials such that things were getting
heated at the wrong time and things were
flowing properly to make sure that
um the order of events would work out so
with a lot of things in biology you know
the steps of
um the steps really matter the
temperature really matters and so there
was a level of precision that was really
needed on the microfluidic chip to make
sure this would all work out properly
especially with a system that integrates
land because lamp is so so active you
wanted to make sure that there really
wasn't going to be any
um interplay between different
components at the wrong time such that
it might activate the reaction too early
and so that was really a huge benefit of
getting to again collaborate with anger
lab Mohammed is somebody who was really
an expert at microphobics and so it was
a pleasure to get to develop this chip
um with him and it was a really great
collaborative and Innovative process we
worked incredibly quickly and every day
you know we would just be printing new
chips in order to try and test them and
the workflow of the chip is
um through simple preparation region
there's an amplification region a
sensing region and a readout region and
this is specific to the um the crispr
um assay so again the um
antibody essay is just a direct saliva
assay
um but the crispr the crispr RNA
detection I say requires a lot of sort
of pre-processing that we wanted to make
sure we were automating and so a lot of
this work is really just automating that
system
um and so the way the chip works the
first region is where you add a saliva
so you add saliva both to the sample
preparation reservoir for the RNA
detection as well as to the
um antibody detection region and they're
separated because the antibody section
does not need processing but the RNA
saliva will need processing and so they
were going to go through a bit of a
different experience
um and so the next system the next step
is after adding the produce K and having
an incubation area an incubation with a
protonase K and then a high heat
inactivation of that protonase K as well
as an activation of any other nucleuses
that might be or in Inhibitors when
present in the saliva we then pump it
through into the reaction chamber and
the reaction chamber um actually has
this PES filter that's inside of it so
the PES filter is what's actually going
to start grabbing on to the nucleic
acids that are present within the saliva
and make sure that we're concentrating
them so this allows us in that first two
steps to both inactivate um and lice the
cells necessary to release the nucleic
acid of interest in our case this is
sarcoid2 RNA and then following you
through the reaction chamber allows us
to concentrate that RNA which means that
we are working with the saliva sample of
about four or 500 microliters we're able
to concentrate all of the RNA present
within that larger volume so that it can
be run for a very small volume
amplification so after concentrating on
this and that's usually sorry using the
peristaltic pumps so pumping the liquid
through the reaction chamber we then
move on to the lamp section so we flow
the lamp reagents into the reaction
chamber and allow that to incubate
um you know we are overshooting things
in the system so we incubate it for 30
minutes but usually Within 15 minutes
you've already got a really robust
signal
again lamp of people aren't familiar
uses two to three pairs of primers and
it allows for a really sensitive and
really rapid amplification of the
nucleic acid of Interest the beauty of
using fluid eplification assay means
that we can actually also just run it
for RNA and DNA so it didn't matter much
when you're using other amplification
assays you might have to add more
additives and obviously reverse
transcript pieces in order to run this
reaction and then moving on after the
incubation with the lamp we flow the
crisper mix directly into the reaction
chamber which means that the lamp assay
as well as crispr reagents and also a
bit of water for dilution so the lamp is
so powerful that we actually have to
dilute the reaction in order to be able
to get the type of
um
sensitivity that would allow us to get a
readable signal if we just flow the
crispr directly into lamp reactions
sometimes it's too much and everything
goes haywire and it just starts slicing
everything so the dilution is really
important to make sure that we can get a
really sensitive and readable signal
within the system
um and we you know had to titrate a lot
of that crisper lamp reaction in order
to make sure that it was at the right
ratio which would work for our system
um as we know the way that Christopher
Castro works as I've said before is that
it does the cleavage of this Illustrated
DNA and so the benefit of this is that
you are now sensing within the system
after amplifying it whether or not that
star Scooby to um
RNA that you're interested in whether or
not it's actually present within the
reaction and so that is this step is
where actually the cleavage of the
single stranded um biotinylated DNA is
going on and after you complete that we
flow everything onto the chip so we can
fill its lab onto the trip and we can
flow
um
the um
crispr RNA reaction onto the chimp they
all get flown over all the different
compartments so there are four different
areas on this e-wrapid chip that you
could have reactions on so the chip that
we've created which I'll speak about in
a minute
um has the three different
um antibodies of Interest as well as the
PNA which is detecting the RNA and
they're all extremely selective for
their different
um
biomolecules of interest and so you can
flow all of the material over all of the
different
um Wells and it's completely fine
because they will be very selective for
what they're meant to be grabbing onto
and after you flow the reaction over it
you can then start doing
um following the polyhrp and the tmb to
get the chip result and what you'll get
is electrochemical signals for all of
the different
um
all the different probes that you have
and you can then be determining whether
or not the antibodies in the RNA are
present within your sample
um and then we did Multiplex chips that
we were running through the entire
system that again as I was saying have
the spike protein
um the RBD the nucleotide and the PNA
and we were able to uh run about 12
samples that were showing 100
correlation with what we were seeing in
the samples
um using Eliza's and PCR versus what we
were getting from our chip
um which was really I think a very
exciting setup because not only is the
chimp really sensitive and really
selective and works very well for these
different types of molecules but we were
actually also able to run the whole
system on the microfluidic chip and have
we can keep the sensitivity that we were
getting when we were also doing all the
different individual steps
um
and I think what
um can be great for the future is
thinking about how these types of
systems these Multiplex systems that we
can run autonomously and we can run on
chips how we can integrate those both
into clinical settings but also at home
settings to figure out how we can
develop better faster more sensitive and
more selective tools that we can use in
order to detect future pathogens and and
even do environmental monitoring to make
sure that we are getting the health and
safety of ourselves and our loved ones
at the Forefront and I think there's so
many places that we can go with this
system which is so exciting to me I
think it would be great to try and
integrate more quantitation into the
system so right now with the
amplification that we're using in this
case land but typically most Sherlock
assays are not quantitative there yes no
which for things like a pandemic is more
than enough but for diseases where you
might want more quantitation or
something quantitation we would need to
develop a bit different systems in order
to make sure that you're getting the
sensitivity being the sensitivity goal
that you want but also trying to get a
quantitative signal
these electrochemical sensors have been
shown to be reusable but we haven't for
this specific use case try to test the
reusability particularly for the crispr
assay so it would be great to try and
run future reactions to understand the
reusability of these chips and the
reusability which would then bring the
cost down and increase it the
accessibility of the system and also
just ways of further automating the
systems so right now we have these
autonomous chips but how can create how
can we create devices that would allow
for you know full automation that people
can run in their homes which is more of
a product question than anything but
would be really exciting to see as well
as just developing larger infrastructure
for related monitoring so a lot of talk
has been going on around things like
sewage monitoring that's been happening
and I think it would be really exciting
to get to use these systems to try and
create better Lane and monitoring
Frameworks for biological monitoring
with within our environment to
understand things like epidemiological
signals within
um the you know cities and and towns and
homes that we live within that would be
um ideal so
thank you so much for coming to this
talk I hope that you enjoyed
um please read the paper if you're
interested and feel free to reach out